la pénurie de carburant qui a bloqué le
cirque Zavata à tour après s'être
produit ici l'équipe devait se rendre à
Épinal pour une série de représentation
mais avec le blocage des dépôts de
carburant ils ont préféré ne pas prendre
la route conséquence il a fallu les
loger en quelque sorte ils ont pu
s'installer sur des parkings de centres
commerciaux un échange de bons procédés
puisqu'il continuent les représentations
on écoute le chargé de communication du
cirque au micro de Julien Gautier là
pour l'instant on est ici à la riche
pour jours et nous partons après 15
jours à Hamp Nord sur le parking pendant
une quinzaine de jours il nous reste à
combler une 15 jours sur la fin du mois
puisque tout est décalé maintenant et
les autres villes ne pouvaient pas
suivre ah ben on est obligé de
travailler parce qu'on a d'énormes frais
journaliers nous avons des artistes
extérieurs et puis nous avons 70
personnes à faire vivre les animaux et
donc c'était impossible c'est c'est
possible pour les tout petits cirques
familiaux de s'arrêter peut-être de ou
TR jours mais nous c'est pas possible
nous sommes une entreprise une PME qui
doit tourner tous les jours